you know there's a lot of people that
have problems with erectile dysfunction
and they try different medications like
viagra i think there's about four more
that they might try and
sometimes it will help them sometimes it
doesn't and sometimes you can give them
side effects and of course the ideal
situation would be to find the root
cause and correct that or at the very
minimum
take something that doesn't give you all
these other side effects because there's
quite a few side effects not to mention
the small ones like headache low blood
pressure dizziness
but also heart attacks so there are
dangerous side effects to taking any
medication
of course with this video i'm not
telling you not to take any medications
check with your doctor before
implementing what i'm going to recommend
now if you research this problem you're
going to find
you know they'll say it's complex
there's a lot of unknowns there's a
combination between
hormonal imbalances neurological
problems and a vascular
problem with risk factors being aging
smoking drinking obesity diabetes stress
heart disease and inflammation well
that's all fine but what's really at the
heart of this problem that's what i want
to know
i always get clues by studying the
mechanism of how medications work so if
we look at viagra for example
it works by inhibiting a certain enzyme
in fact most medications either inhibit
an enzyme or stimulate an enzyme enzymes
in the body are proteins and they do
certain functions in the body and so
with the case of viagra
it inhibits this pde5
which is involved with smooth muscle
of someone's penis now
to make this really simple there's a
whole cascade of effects that occur
when you take this enzyme inhibitor okay
with the end result being enhanced
nitric oxide which affects the nerves
and the arteries
which gives you a prolonged erection
because the smooth muscle is now relaxed
allowing blood flow into the penis
without the venous flow coming out so
basically it keeps the blood flow from
leaving okay and so that is how
this medication works
and of course the question i have is is
there a natural pde5 inhibitor and the
answer is yes there is and there's some
other solutions
this mechanism works indirectly there
are other treatments that work directly
by increasing nitric oxide which
again does this thing i just mentioned
right here
like for example there's a nitroglycerin
cream
which has
less side effects it has a direct effect
it works quicker but it does have side
effects and you have to go to the doctor
and they have to adjust the dosage some
people also use something called
l-arginine which is an amino acid which
actually there's some studies that shows
that it works so that's another option
that you have
i've done videos in the past about zinc
well zinc will increase testosterone and
it will increase sperm count but
apparently there's no real studies that
i could find that it will help someone
with erectile dysfunction but these are
the
four things that i'm going to focus on
today number one
fasting
yeah and i'm going to put these studies
down below fasting can actually increase
nitric oxide and there's been a lot of
success stories that i've heard over the
years where people start to improve
erectile dysfunction once they start
fasting
of course that's probably because
they have blood sugar issues either
they're overweight or they have diabetes
or insulin resistance
so of course fasting is going to correct
that there's also herbal versions of
this enzyme inhibitor okay horny goat
weed
forskolin
as well as black
ginger
so a lot of people get results
with these and they have
much less side effects
also exercise specifically weight
training and or intense exercise with
good recovery because if there's too
much stress and not enough sleep
that's going to nullify the results but
this is another one that is
credible and there's some great studies
on that and number four which i want to
talk about which is an interesting
uh modality it's called low intensity
shock wave therapy now
this term shockwave kind of scares
people but it's low intensity shockwave
okay apparently they use this therapy
for a lot of different things with
different intensity of waves they can
use it to break up kidney stones they
use it for
bursitis tendinitis
because if you lower the intensity of a
wave you can create an anti-inflammatory
effect but with these devices which they
have like centers that you can go to to
get this procedure done
and they also have do-it-yourself
devices
what it does is it creates a micro
trauma okay a very small trauma just
like exercise which then results in
increased
blood vessels called
neovascularization as well as breaking
up plaquing if there's plaquing in the
penis so apparently it's a great rehab
with some pretty hardcore
placebo-controlled uh clinical trials
with some studies that show up to 70
results the thing i like about this is
there's very minimal
side effects so something to research
i've given you four things right here
and there's just one last point i want
to emphasize
and that is
stress okay if someone is stressed out
they're not going to be sleeping so if
they're not sleeping
okay
they're going to be on the sympathetic
or fly to fight dominant mode they're
going to have
low amounts of parasympathetic as far as
the underlying cause we have a situation
where the person is usually sympathetic
dominant they're usually not sleeping
that great they're usually stressed out
they have a low parasympathetic reserve
so it's going to be very difficult to
maintain an erection
so another really important point that
goes beyond diet is really handling this
recovery
stress sleep situation and for that data
you should probably watch this video
right here
you